Welcome back to your Danish citizenship exam companion.
This is Chapter Six, Episode Sixteen: discrimination, antisemitism, hate crimes and extremism.
Denmark is built on ideals of, among other things, freedom and democracy.
These ideals are laid down in Denmark's constitution, grundloven.
The constitution for example determines that you can say or write what you want, freedom of expression.
The constitution also determines that you can choose the religion you wish, freedom of religion.
The constitution also protects the right to form associations, freedom of association, and to assemble, for example for demonstrations, freedom of assembly.
But it is illegal to misuse the freedom for certain forms of discrimination, diskrimination.
There is discrimination if you treat people differently and worse because of their faith, political conviction, skin colour, sex, ethnicity, sexual orientation, age and so on.
People often say that "freedom must be used with responsibility".
In general, ideals of equality and democracy have high support in Denmark, but there are also examples of discrimination.
Studies indicate that almost half of all citizens with a non-Western immigrant background in Denmark have experienced being discriminated against in some way because of their ethnic origin.
Studies show that applicants with certain foreign names have a harder time getting a rented home or being invited to a job interview, even if they are just as qualified as the applicants with typically Danish names.
You also must not publicly say or write anything that degrades, ridicules or threatens others because of, for example, their race, skin colour, faith or sexual orientation.
Likewise it is illegal to use your freedom of expression to publicly call for a crime to be committed, for example by calling for violence against a particular group of people.
You must also not publicly express your clear support for a terror attack that has already been committed.
Many of these rules are made to protect religious, ethnic and sexual minorities against abuse from the state and against abuse from other citizens.
To protect minorities you can thus punish crimes particularly severely if they are committed because of the victim's ethnic origin, faith, sexual orientation or similar.
Such crimes are also called hate crimes, hadforbrydelser.
In the period 2022 to 24, the police in Denmark registered 2,108 cases of hate crimes.
1,022 of them, 48 percent, were because of the victims' race or ethnicity, 756, 36 percent, because of the victims' religion, and 435, 21 percent, because of the victims' sexual orientation.
The crimes are typically hateful statements, violence, vandalism or threats.
This corresponds to 702 hate crimes on average per year in the period, or about two cases every day.
The Jewish minority in Denmark is an example of a group that is particularly exposed to hate crimes.
In the period 2022 to 24, the police registered 430 hate crimes against Jews.
That is a high number considering that only a total of 6,000 to 8,000 Jews live in Denmark.
More than half of the hate crimes committed in Denmark because of the victim's religion, and more than every fifth of all hate crimes in Denmark, were committed against Jews.
For example, gravestones in a Jewish cemetery in Randers in 2019 were doused with paint and knocked over by men from a neo-Nazi movement.
It happened symbolically on the 9th of November, that is on the anniversary of Kristallnacht in 1938, when the Nazis, among other things, smashed and burned Jewish shops, synagogues, homes and schools in Germany.
After the conflict between Israel and Hamas began in October 2023, Jewish citizens in Denmark increasingly experienced threats and harassment.
Much of this has taken place online, for example via social media such as Facebook, Instagram and X, where they have, among other things, been held responsible for Israel's policy towards the Palestinians.
In several cases this has happened with hateful comments and Nazi symbols such as the swastika.
On the 5th of May 2023, that is the anniversary of Denmark's liberation in 1945, a memorial stone in Copenhagen for the Danes' help for the Danish Jews during the Second World War was doused with red paint.
The most serious example of an antisemitic act in Denmark in recent times is probably the terror attack in 2015, where a terrorist with sympathy for the terror organisation Islamic State shot and killed a Jewish guard.
It happened when the terrorist in vain tried to force his way into the synagogue in central Copenhagen.
There are also examples of hate crimes against other groups.
For example, a Danish party leader was in 2020 convicted for, in a video, saying that "the Danes and Denmark are far too highly developed and advanced to be able to coexist with the very low-grade Muslim cultural rubbish".
And in 2025, three persons were sentenced to between six and ten months in prison for aggravated violence after having assaulted, hit, kicked and stamped on the heads of two homosexual men.
One of the men was also convicted for having filmed the incident and shared it on social media.
In 2015, Nazi graffiti with threats was painted and a car was set on fire at an asylum centre by a perpetrator who was an opponent of the Danish refugee policy.
The perpetrator was sentenced to one and a half years in prison.
At other times crimes are committed because the perpetrators do not like the victim's political views.
In 2003 the then prime minister Anders Fogh Rasmussen and foreign minister Per Stig Møller were attacked with paint in the Folketing because of Denmark's support for the USA's invasion of Iraq, the Iraq War.
The two perpetrators were sentenced to three and four months in prison respectively.
The courts thought it was particularly serious that they had attacked representatives of democracy.
In recent decades the Police Intelligence Service, PET, has had to protect an increasing number of politicians with bodyguards, because PET assesses that more politicians are threatened by attacks or harassment.
Here is your recap for Episode Sixteen.
The constitution protects freedom of expression, religion, association and assembly.
Discrimination is treating people worse because of faith, political conviction, skin colour, sex, ethnicity, sexual orientation, age and so on.
You must not publicly degrade, ridicule or threaten others because of race, skin colour, faith or sexual orientation, nor call for crimes or support a terror attack that has been committed.
Crimes committed because of the victim's ethnic origin, faith or sexual orientation are hate crimes and can be punished more severely.
In 2022 to 24, the police registered 2,108 hate crimes: 48 percent for race or ethnicity, 36 percent for religion, 21 percent for sexual orientation; about two cases a day.
430 were against Jews, though only 6,000 to 8,000 Jews live in Denmark.
The 2015 terror attack, at the Jewish synagogue in central Copenhagen, killed a Jewish guard outside it; it was not at the central station or the airport.
In 2003 the prime minister Anders Fogh Rasmussen and the foreign minister Per Stig Møller were attacked with paint in the Folketing.
PET protects an increasing number of politicians.
Now it is time for your exam practice.
These are real questions from past Danish citizenship exams on what you just heard.
For each one, I will read the question and the choices, then pause so you can pick your answer, and then I will give you the correct answer.
Question 1.
At which place in Copenhagen was a terror attack carried out in 2015?
Option A: At the Jewish synagogue.
Option B: At the Central Station.
Option C: At the airport.
[DA] Hvilket af følgende steder i København blev der begået et terrorangreb i 2015?  A: Ved den jødiske synagoge  |  B: Ved Hovedbanegården  |  C: I lufthavnen
The answer is A: At the Jewish synagogue.
It appeared in the May 2023 exam.
[DA] ✔ A: Ved den jødiske synagoge
That's the end of this part.
Well done.